who gets to go with you so you will mike
brown and those guys go with you this
time
yeah so um my boxing coaching kickboxing
coach are going to stay behind and catch
the next charter
mike brown is going to come with me to
vegas and come with me to abu dhabi
and the rest of my team and my wife will
get there
i think four days after after i get
there so
it's good they'll they'll go through
their two-day quarantine when they land
and then we'll all be able to
start training and stuff but i'll be out
there 13 days before the fight so i
think that'll be
enough because we're also fighting early
morning abu dhabi time
so at first i thought i need to get out
there to get adjusted to the time
um but the the cards going live
normal pay-per-view time here so 10
eastern the pay-per-view goes live wow
but it'll be
whatever it is eight or nine a.m what a
night of fight it's gonna be the biggest
fight since trump biden i think
yeah probably yeah you know it'll be up
there or since cove at modernist since
that new vaccine came out so what will
you do to like adjust like your sleep
patterns and stuff will you like
what did you learn last time that you
went there see last time we fought on
uae time so this is completely different
ah i see what you're saying so you're
fighting on the u.s time i'm fighting on
u.s time last time we fought
uae russia time but is that going to be
weird you wake up in the morning and
then you go fight
[ __ ] punches and pancakes yeah yeah
yeah now that's what you should throw in
lafayette punches and paint which isn't
pancakes
yeah but it'll be normal time in life
yeah yeah damn
[ __ ] we should not come up we would you
just keep spitballing here yeah yeah
something'll stick you know yeah um
but i'm gonna um start doing some late
night runs like around uh because you
have a plan right 12 eastern i'll start
doing some some sweats
keep it up when i go out to vegas and
then hopefully when i land there i'm
landing there in the morning so i'm
gonna just get off the plane and start
my day
try to go to sleep a little early and
wake up earlier so i'm gonna try to get
up around like
six seven a.m abu dhabi time when i land
out there
just to give me a couple hours before
i'll be fighting connor you know
you don't be young yeah you're someone
beyond and that's a bad luck yeah yeah
and mike brennan will be able to go yeah
oh that's awesome man so everybody will
be there
dude that's freaking dude honestly and
and it's exciting because it's a new
journey for me with all this quarantine
and
the hustle of traveling to different
locations just to get to the fight
so i'm excited man let's start the
journey yeah like i don't know what's
gonna [ __ ] happen but let's go
yeah it's gonna be fun i mean to think
that i know i'm gonna fight i know that
part's gonna happen right but all the
other stuff is like exciting
the weight cut and and you know not i
can't bring my nutritionist with me i
usually have a team of nutritionists who
cook the meals and do all this stuff for
me
so i don't [ __ ] know damn bro but
when will you be able to start eating
again oh after the weigh-in
after the week so how long is that
weight cut time i mean i'm starting
kind of starting my weight cut now
getting getting you know i've been
dieting for the last eight weeks
hardcore mm-hmm i think i came out here
at like 182 pounds maybe
yeah and then i'll be on january 23rd or
january 22nd i'll be 155.
so you have to lose like 15 percent of
your body
there's a math thing again yeah that's
true and i and that was definitely that
was a guess yeah yeah
but you have it's like imagine if
somebody said cut your arm up and put
your arm somewhere that's crazy
yeah you know yeah it's i mean it's like
it's a good bit of a
good bit of weight 155 is getting tough
for me to make now man yeah yeah
could this be your last fight at 155 i
definitely believe i'm gonna fight at
170 i don't know how many times in the
ufc i fought at 170 before in my career
before but uh never in the ufc but i
think i'm going to fight one stephanie
before
you know this eight fights run out i'm
gonna i'm gonna fight somebody
welterweight
i'm just glad you and i could have a
good conversation before you go through
eight more fights
yeah and the subtitles we're having to
write stuff on the board
yeah and put it back and forth between
each other
i'm just sitting on your front porch
wondering how could i be so far
from my home
and my mind is somewhere else but when i
find it i'll patch up where it's been
[Music]
brown